fortes chaleurs et faibles
précipitations depuis le début du
printemps
la combinaison parfaite pour que la
sécheresse s'installe dans le loiret 78
communes sur 334 étaient déjà concernés
par des mesures de restrictions d'eau
aujourd'hui elles sont 115 nouvelle zone
d' alerte du côté de l'ars doués du
fusain situation de sécheresse renforcer
et de crise ce sont essentiellement le
sud ouest et l'est du département qui
sont concernés pour les agriculteurs
cela impacte l'irrigation avec des
diminutions restriction voire
d'interdiction des prélèvements pour les
particuliers les principales mesures
portent sur l'arrosage des pelouses
limités ou interdits selon les secteurs
il est conseillé de se renseigner auprès
de sa mairie vous pouvez continuer
d'arroser vos potagers mais seulement
entre 20 heures et 8 heures du matin
pour les voitures privilégiez les
centres de lavage spécialisés quant aux
piscines
il va falloir faire avec ce qui est déjà
dans les bassins interdiction de les
remplir